JOINING US IS FORMER DEPUTY
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH MATTHEWS.
SARAH, YOU HAD A SIMILAR
REACTION LAST NIGHT TO JEB BUSH
WHO WAS MOCKING TRUMP SAYING
WHAT A LOW ENERGY SPEECH BY THE
DONALD, TIME FOR NEW LEADERS.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> YEAH, IT WAS JUST THAT.
IT WAS LOW ENERGY, UNINSPIRING,
DURING MY TIME WORKING FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I WATCHED HIM
GIVE HUNDREDS OF SPEECHES OVER
THE TWO YEARS I WORKED FOR HIM.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST BORING.
HE HIMSELF SEEMED BOARING GIVING
THE SPEECH YOU CAN TELL HE WAS
TRYING TO STAY ON SCRIPT BUT
THEN STARTED TO GET BORED AND AD
LIB AND IT TURNED INTO A
RAMBLING MESS IN MY OPINION.
>> THE NATIONAL REVIEW THIS
MORNING REFLECTS WHAT A LOT OF
FORMER ALLIES OF THE PRESIDENT,
REPUBLICANS, ARE THINKING AND
SAYING THE HEADLINE IS JUST NO.
THE FIRST LINE IS TO PARAPHRASE
VOLUNTARY AFTER HE ATTENDED AN
ORGY, ONCE WAS AN EXPERIMENT
TWICE WOULD BE PERVERSE.
>> POPPY, SO EARLY.
>> I KNOW.
I DIDN'T WRITE IT, THEY WROTE
IT.
DO YOU THINK IT'S JUST THE MEDIA
BEHIND HIM THAT'S TURNED AND A
LOT OF REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS AND
QUOTE/UNQUOTE ELITES.
DOES THAT INDICATE ANYTHING
ABOUT HIS ARDENT FOLLOWERS?
>> I THINK IT'S NOT.
I THINK WE NEED TO PASS OVER
HIM.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, HE'S
SHOWN THAT HE'S NOT FIT TO
SERVE.
I THINK THAT BY, YOU KNOW,
PERSONALLY BY INCITING AN
INSURRECTION, I THINK THAT HE'S
UNFIT TO HOLD OFFICE EVER AGAIN.
BUT I DO THINK THAT LAST NIGHT'S
SPEECH SHOWED HE'S UNINSPIRING.
IT WAS KIND OF THE SAME SPEECH I
HEARD HIM GIVE OVER THE YEARS,
THERE WAS NOTHING NEW TO IT.
IT WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
HIS FOLLOWERS A FORWARD LOOKING
MESSAGE.
AND THIS WAS AN UNINSPIRED
SPEECH.
>> WE SHOULD REMIND VIEWERS
SARAH QUICK THE DAY AFTER THE
INSURRECTION BECAUSE OF WHAT HE
DID.
>> AND THIS IS BREAKING, DONALD
TRUMP WHO TRIED TO OVERTHROW THE
RESULTS OF THE 2020 ELECTION AND
INSPIRED A DEADLY RIOT AT THE
CAPITOL HAS FILED TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN IN 2024.
THAT IS CHALKED FULL OF NUTS AS
THEY SAY AND EXPLAIN WHAT
HAPPENS HAPPENED IN THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS IN ONE SENTENCE.
THE QUESTION IS WHY IS HE
DEFYING MEMBERS OF HIS OWN
PARTIES, ALLIES WHO LOVED HIM
BEFORE, WHO ARE NOW SAYING DON'T
DO THIS.
AND AS POPPY POINTED OUT, NO
FROM THE NATIONAL REVIEW.
WHY IS HE DOING IT?
>> I THINK HE THINKS THIS IS A
POTENTIAL WAY FOR HIM TO AVOID,
YOU KNOW, THESE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE SWARMING
AROUND HIM.
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S HIS OWN
EGO.
HE CAN'T ADMIT TO HIMSELF THAT
HE LOST THE 2020 ELECTION.
SO HE THINKS THAT HE NEEDS TO
PROBABLY PROVE SOMETHING TO HIS
FOLLOWERS OR TO HIMSELF AND I DO
THINK THAT WE DO NEED TO MOVE IN
A NEW DIRECTION.
I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS,
BOTH PUBLICALLY AND PRIVATELY
HAVE EXPRESSED DISMAY THAT HE
ANNOUNCED SO EARLY.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE GEORGIA
SENATE RUNOFF HAPPENING.
I THINK ALL FOCUS FOR
REPUBLICANS SHOULD BE ON THAT.
BUT THAT'S GOING TO HARM
HERSCHEL WALKER WITH THIS EARLY
ANNOUNCEMENT AS WELL.
>> IT DOESN'T SHIELD HIM.
BUT SIT AN OFFER HE BELIEVES, A
NARRATIVE HE CAN SELL TO VOTERS.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T SHIELD HIM
THAT HE'S RUNNING.
>> NO, I COMPLETELY AGREE.
IT DOES NOT SHIELD HIM FROM
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS.
BUT I DO THINK THAT IT'S HIS WAY
OF THEN IF THEY DO COME AT HIM,
HE CAN MAKE THAT CASE TO HIS
VOTERS LOOK THIS IS ALL
POLITICAL.
THEY'RE GOING AFTER ME BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT ME TO BE
PRESIDENT AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT SEEMS TO BE THE CASE
IN MY OPINION.
>> I'M TOLD THAT IS PART OF WHAT
DROVE THE ANNOUNCEMENT LAST
NIGHT, WHY IT WAS SO EARLY,
BECAUSE OF THE INVESTIGATIONS.
SARAH, YOU WORKED IN THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE, I WAS IN THE
BRIEFING ROOM AT THE TIME.
I WONDER THE STAFFING WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE.
BECAUSE IVANKA TRUMP PUT OUT A
STATEMENT SAYING I DO NOT PLAN
TO BE INVOLVED IN POLITICS.
I'LL ALWAYS LOVE AND SUPPORT MY
FATHER, DOING SO I'LL DO SO
OUTSIDE THE POLITICAL ARENA.
DO YOU THINK A LOT OF YOUR
FORMER COLLEAGUES WILL GO BACK
TO WORK FOR TRUMP AGAIN?
>> I THINK SOME OF THE BIGGER
NAMES THAT YOU'VE SEEN, I DON'T
THINK THEY WILL GO BACK AND WORK
FOR HIM.
YOU KNOW, IVANKA MADE CLEAR SHE
WILL NOT BE PLAYING A ROLE IF HE
ENDS UP WINNING ANOTHER
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
I THINK THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE SOME OF THE SAME FOLKS,
THOUGH, FROM THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION STICK WITH HIM.
A LOT OF THEM ARE STILL DOWN IN
MAR-A-LAGO WITH HIM TO THIS DAY.
AND I THINK THAT THERE IS A
CHANCE THAT SOME OF THOSE FOLKS
WILL GO BACK.
I WILL NOT BE ONE OF THEM.
NOT THAT I WOULD BE WELCOME BACK
ANYWAYS.
BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE GOING BACK
AND WORKING FOR HIM AFTER
WATCHING HIM PUSH ALL OF THESE
LIES ABOUT THE ELECTION AND
OBVIOUSLY WHAT HE DID ON JANUARY
6TH, 2021 AS WELL.
>> SARAH MATTHEWS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.